alright so we're here in flipping mutt  cuts mobile saddle up partner for dumb  and dumber 2 and look at this merch dude  this is awesome i have to get one see it  alright so this is the actual tuxedo  that they wore in the bullets it's  t-shirt version but it's a tuxedo that  they wear and then looking at the blue  one how great that is it's so amazing  that you want a dumb shirt yeah all  right we go already yo dawg you want to  share it Wow  yeah people are so happy for shirts oh  yo SDPD would you like a dumb and dumber  shirt it's on me baby all right don't  want to [ __ ] yeah yeah yeahs always  going from you I need one hold on quick  oh my god who wants a dumb shirt ah high  five Dumb and Dumber shirt three two one  that was fun hey when hear the most  annoying sound in the world  you